we are delighted to bring you this
seminar presented by labyrinths
welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's keynote
presentation titled
the massively parallel sequencing
revolution
it is my pleasure to introduce you to dr
david smith
professor and consultant department of
laboratory medicine
and pathology mayo clinic dr david smith
received his phd in biochemistry from
the university of wisconsin in madison
in 1978 studying antibiotic resistance
in bacteria his laboratory studies the
common fragile sites which are regions
of profound genomic
instability that are found in all
individuals dr smith is also the
chairman of technology assessment group
for the mayo clinic center
for individualized medicine
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will respond back to you via
email
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
please join me in welcoming dr smith i
will now turn the presentation over
to him hi i'm david smith
i'm a professor and consultant in the
department of laboratory medicine and
pathology
at the mayo clinic i am also the
chairman of the technology assessment
committee
of the mayo clinic center for
individualized medicine
today i'm going to be talking about the
massively parallel sequencing revolution
an abbreviation for that is mps
all of the things that i'm going to be
talking about came about as a result of
the technology revolution
and all of the sequencing technologies
are highly dependent upon
technological advances that first
enabled one to generate the necessary
data
but as important is the ability to
analyze the data that is generated
all of the ability to analyze the data
is predicated upon
advances that have occurred in computers
with the doubling of computing speed
every 18 months all one has to do is
compare today's laptop computer to the
best computers that were available to
supercomputers ten years ago
that's how much sequence computing
technologies have moved forward
and the key features in the advances at
computers are the computing speed or the
cycles
having sufficient ram and data storage
because for when we talk about things
like sequencing complex genomes
we're talking about massive amounts of
data that needs to be
taken and analyzed
everything that i'm going to talk about
today involves the analysis of dna
and when we think about dna we have
basically four nucleotides
a c g and t however
there is an additional nucleotide that
has to be considered
and that is 5-methylcytosine which is
the methylation of cytosine which is an
epigenetic
modification rna can also be analyzed
but the technologies that i'm going to
be talking about in my talk which are
first
generation sequencing technologies you
first have to convert that rna into
cdna to copy it with something like
reverse transcriptase
what i show here is the actual structure
of a double-stranded dna molecule
that is in the process of replicating as
the two strands come apart
what happens is you have the capability
of making a copy of each strand
the information on any one of the
strands is sufficient
to get the copy of the second strand so
as that dna replicates and as it unfolds
if you have a t the only base that can
base pair with that is an a if you have
a g
the only base that can see etc
now this is the actual structure of
just a linear dna molecule and what we
have at the top
is is just sort of a caricature of that
showing sort of the backbone and then
the nucleotides themselves
are the things that are in the middle at
the bottom is actually a more
structure of what it actually looks like
with the atoms themselves
this is the canonical double helix that
we all talk about
however the dna that we have that in
humans
is not existing as just this naked
molecule on the next slide
we see that the dna double helix which
is shown at the top
which is directly equivalent to what i
showed on the previous slide
is actually wrapped into chromatin there
are actual proteins that bind to that
dna
and begin to do a wrapping process the
first step is you have sort of beads on
a string which is a very loose form of
chromatin
that can be compressed down into a
chromatin fiber
which are actually packed nucleosomes on
the second slide and the second
the thing you see actually the
nucleosomes which are just the wrap dna
around the protein
that chromatin fiber is further
compressed to be an extended section of
a chromosome
that can be even further compressed to
be a condensed section of a chromosome
and when it's fully compressed one has
the metaphase chromosome which is the
way
that chromosomes would traditionally
visualized
this slide actually shows the
morphologies of each of the human
chromosomes
after they have been banded with
something which is called g
banding and g banding is the use of a
stain called
gimsa with [ __ ] sustaining you can
actually there's actually two pictures
here one is
basically just an electromicrograph
showing each of the chromosomes
and then the small little insert next to
it shows the actual
banding with g banding of the individual
chromosomes
and you have the largest chromosome is
chromosome 1
all the way down to the last autosome
which is chromosome
22 and then the sex chromosomes the x
and the y chromosome
if one prepares a metaphase preparation
of these chromosomes
this is what they look like and you see
sort of just looks like little
spaghettis
of the individual chromosomes while it's
relatively easy to discern larger
chromosomes from smaller chromosomes
it's very difficult to tell the
difference between chromosomes that of
the same size
however with the g banding with the [ __ ]
sustaining of the chromosomes
you suddenly have a banding that enables
you to take
this mix of chromosomes and actually
assort them
and align them to say which are the two
chromosome ones
which are the two chromosome twos and
the picture
shown here is actually a metaphase
a karyotype of a human female you can
tell because there are two x chromosomes
on the bottom right
you see the two chromosome ones the two
chromosome twos
and with the banding it thus becomes
easy
to discern one chromosome from another
obviously the larger chromosomes
are easy to sort of look at than for
example the small chromosomes chromosome
21
and 22. now this
karyotyping and the ability to look at
chromosomes in this way
was very powerful because with this it
became possible
to look at different diseases in
abnormal states to see if
they had anything to do with alterations
that occurred in the chromosomes
and one of the very interesting early
findings is shown on this next slide
this is the karyotype of an individual
who has
a chronic myelogenous leukemia otherwise
known as cml
the chromosomes look pretty normal
normal chromosome 1 normal chromosome 2
etc as you start to go through the
karyotype
but all of a sudden when one looks at
chromosome 9
you can see that there are two different
looking chromosome nines
similarly when you look at chromosome 22
you also see two different chromosomes
what has occurred
in this individual what has occurred in
every every leukemic cell in this
patient with cml
is actually a balanced reciprocal
translocation
a little piece of chromosome 9 has come
off of that chromosome and is
translocated to chromosome 22
the other piece has moved to chromosome
9. and this is shown on the right
you basically have this the normal
chromosome 9
versus the 9 q plus this is the
chromosome that has a tiny little piece
of chromosome 22 attached to it
similarly with the chromosome 22 you
have the normal chromosome 22
but the 22q minus where the tiny piece
has moved
now what has occurred in this and this
look and this karyotype
revealed something very interesting at
the molecular level because what is
actually occurring at the position where
these chromosomes have broken off
is that two genes have been translocated
to each other
this is what is called the philadelphia
chromosome this was called that because
for the investigator
who found this was working in the city
of philadelphia
and basically this is a balanced
reciprocal translocation
and as a result of this two genes one
called bcr
and the other called able have actually
been translocated next to each other
and this occurs in 90 percent of the
patients who have cml
now able is actually a tyrosine kinase
and when bcr enable have been
translocated next to each other
and again this occurs in 90 of the
patients with cml
what happens is the there is a promoter
on the bcr
region which activates able and the
activation of that tyrosine kinase is
the trigger
that triggers the development of cml
well it turns out
imatinib is actually a tyrosine kinase
inhibitor
and investigators once they realized
what was occurring in these
came to the realization that if they use
a tyrosine kinase inhibitor this
might inhibit the growth of the cml
cells and indeed
this proved to be true and as a result
of this
this completely changed the course of
chronic myelogenous leukemia
because with the addition of imatinib to
patients who have this translocation
again in ninety percent of the patients
with cml
the survival rates which were less than
thirty percent
prior to this uh advent increased
over seventy percent as a result of
using this tyrosine kinase inhibitor
to inhibit the activated abl which
actually occurs in a majority of the cml
patients
now this thus raises the question are
there thus
easy fixes for other types of cancers it
turns out there are other translocations
that have been found in both leukemias
and in solid tumors but none are as
frequent as the bcr-able translocation
in cml
now when one compares alterations that
occur in the leukemias
to the alterations in solid tumors
traditionally there are less
rearrangements in leukemias than in
solid tumors
so one of the next questions still
remains because of this
real understanding that finding through
cytogenetics by looking at the
chromosomes
that these two genes would juxtapose one
wonders can we do similar things for
other cancers
and would this give rise to
understanding that might suggest
therapeutic things that could target
those cancers that have specific
alterations
well here is a normal female you can see
again
the karyotype and if the the 2x
chromosomes aren't on the bottom right
they're in the middle row to the right
but you see the two normal x chromosomes
this female was
seen at the mayo clinic because she had
a mass
inside of her abdomen and when
this mass was looked at they realized
that there was something
cancerous that was growing in that
individual when the cells from that
mass were taken and looked at this is
shown the karyotype that is now shown on
the bottom
is the karyotype of what something that
obviously looked like an
adenocarcinoma which is compatible with
an ovarian adenocarcinoma
and what you can see immediately as
compared to the very simple karyotype
which was seen in the individual who had
the philadelphia chromosome and chronic
myelogenous leukemia
you see basically a genome which is
dramatically rearranged
there isn't just two chromosome ones
there's actually
three that are slightly different from
each other there's only a single
visible chromosome two there's four
different things that are all compatible
with some
chromosome threes and as one goes
through the entire karyotype
you can see that almost every single
chromosome with the notable exception of
just a few
have some alterations and at the very
bottom
there are a series of chromosomes that
it's difficult to tell exactly what they
are at all they're more than likely
representative
of lots of different chromosomes pieces
that have come together
thus when one looks at many solid tumors
ovarian cancer is a more rearranged
solid tumor but
many solid tumors have much more complex
karyotypes
have many more rearrangements and unlike
the
cml where you have something that occurs
in the majority of patients
it seems like every single solid tumor
has a completely different karyotype
and there haven't been any great
insights to find something that is
occurring in many of those cancers that
could then be a therapeutic target
so how many alterations occur in cancer
well the
real only way to know is it's not
sufficient to use
cytogenetics and karyotype analysis the
only way to know for sure
would be to develop the technological
capabilities
to determine the complete nucleotide
sequence and
structure of a large number of cancer
genomes
as compared to their matched normal
genomes in much the same way that on the
previous slides i showed you the
karyotype of
the female with the ovarian cancer and
then the karyotype of the cancer
well what we would like to do is not
karyotypes because they don't have the
resolution
we would like to compare the nucleotide
sequence of the
normal chromo normal dna from that
individual
to the nucleotide sequence of the cancer
dna
to see what are the alterations
how hard can that be well turns out we
inherit three billion base pairs that
are present in 23 chromosomes from our
mother
and three billion although men have
slightly less dna we're a little
genetically deficient
from our fathers unfortunately what
makes it extremely difficult aside from
the actual
number of nucleotides we're talking
about 6 billion base pairs
is that 45 percent of our genome is
highly repetitive
so in order to determine the sequence of
a genome
let alone a cancer genome you first have
to figure out ways to determine the
sequence of pieces of dna
and then once you've figured a way to
actually determine the sequence of the
tiny pieces or
larger pieces you have to figure out a
way to string it
all together so the very first technique
for dna sequencing
was developed by two scientists maximum
gilbert
and they had a chemical cleavage method
and they their names ended up being on
that method
for determining dna sequence
unfortunately
this was a very cumbersome technique and
very low throughput
in spite of that gregor sutcliffe in
1978
was able to use this technology and to
develop the sequence of a plasmid called
pbr
322. this is about a 2000 little over
2000 base pair plasmid
and using this technique he was able to
do this
this became his phd thesis unfortunately
this is a very cumbersome technique it
costs
10 to 20 dollars or more per nucleotide
this is not going to be a feasible
method for sequencing
things that are much larger however a
number of years later
a technique was developed by fred zanger
that was
we call it sanger sequencing but its
full name is dye deoxy chain termination
sequencing
the way this works is to use chain
terminating nucleotides
in the synthesis so that you can
determine where
the certain bases are if you have a
dideoxya this will terminate
when an a when that is added to a
growing chain and
the very first generation of this
technology was done
by having the actual nucleotides the
dideoxynucleotides being radioactive so
when they were incorporated
you had radioactivity that was
incorporated into that growing chain
what i show here is actually how dna
replicates this is a reminiscent of a
much
earlier slide where i showed the two
chains of dna coming apart
but now we're looking at how a base is
added to that chain you have
template and a primer and this is
actually how sequencing is done
but it's also how dna actually
replicates in vivo
so when you have this the primer which
terminates at this base pair between a
and t
the next available basis of g the only
base that can base pair with this is a
cytosine
so if cytosine is added you will have a
c added to that
but there's a hydroxyl group which is
the group that can now accept the sec
the next nucleotide the next base is in
a so the only base that can come to that
is a t
and you can see that we've now added a g
and a t
the next base that would be added would
be another t
sanger really realizing this said you
know what what if we were to add
dideoxynucleotides die deoxynucleotides
will not have hydroxyl group
at the right end of the base that's
being added they'll just have a hydrogen
so when they're added
only a single base can be added you
cannot add a second base
so utilizing that knowledge you see here
actually how dideoxy sequencing is done
you have four separate reactions a
reaction which is interrogating the
additions
and the positions of every single a in a
chain one for
g one for c and one for t the way sanger
sequencing
works however is to have a very dilute
concentration of die deoxynucleotides
so that on the average most of the time
a regular base is added but when a
dioxybase is added that
terminates the chain so if you do these
reactions you can see in the dideoxy a
lane
that there are three different bands
that occur those are bands because
they're bands where didioxy a was added
either at the first position where there
was a
a second position or the third position
excuse me a t and
you can then do the same thing for the g
the c and the t
and then by looking at these things you
can actually read up and this is shown
on the bottom
you have an a a g two c's
et cetera and you read up to get the
sequence of that little stretch of dna
all of the dye deoxy reactions that are
done and they're done separately
have to be resolved on large gels and
this
shows a typical plate assembly where you
have a plate that could be two meters in
length one to two meters
and it's very thin you will load the dna
reactions the dideoxy reactions at the
top of this thing
you will place this into an
electrophoresis apparatus
with a positive electrode at the bottom
the dna is negatively charged so it'll
run towards the bottom
and when the dye is hit the bottom you
know that all the bases from
the you know short bases to much longer
bases will be on that gel
so after the gel has been run you can
peel apart the two plates
put a piece of water radiographic film
against it expose it overnight
and then what you get is a series of
bands and the actual sequence
can be read up by looking at it you have
a lane for a a t
a g and a c now
the problem with sanger sequencing or
most of the sequencing will be talking
about
is that you are sequencing short
stretches of dna
fortunately with sagger sequencing it is
actually possible to resolve things that
are eight to nine hundred base pairs in
length
but we're talking about genomes which
are considerably larger
well one of the early realizations was
that a very
easy way to use these short sequences to
characterize
longer sequences was to generate a set
of overlapping fragments
and sequence them and then align them
next to each other to look for overlaps
and then this way and what i show is
just an average gene
an average gene which is 10 you know 5
000 to 10 000 base pairs in length
can be characterized by these shorter
pieces of dna
to build up a long sequence and actually
the one of the interesting things is
craig venter was the first person to say
if that's possible to look at a gene
this way
it should equally be possible to perhaps
take an
entire complex genome and do it in the
same way
now unfortunately using dye deoxy
sequencing and radioactive nucleotides
how many sequencing lanes with this type
of technology would it take to sequence
the entire human genome well
it turns out if you can do seven to nine
or base pairs of sequencing on a gel but
you require four lanes to determine the
sequence of one fragment
and you have a six billion base pair
genome it would
turn out to take 222 million lanes
which is 20 to 30 million gels
and this would take a thousand graduate
students working
10 years to do this this is not the cost
at this point was
it was less than maxim gilbert
sequencing but was still
a couple of dollars per base now the
next step
was to actually figure out a way to
automate this
to make this more efficient and actually
once they did this
it thus became possible in the year 2000
to use sanger sequencing
and this was predicated on first
subcloning the little pieces
into bacteria because for sanger
sequencing it requires at least 10 to
the 13 molecules
per every sequence lane
and you can do this by either sequencing
with directed sequencing knowing which
fragment you have
or as craig venter suggested completely
random as shotgun type sequencing
but what needed to be developed is shown
on the next slide
is basically to all instead of using
radioactive dideoxynucleotides
to actually use fluorescent nucleotides
and you can use
four different colors one for a one for
c one for g
and one for t and once that was done and
this was developed by
a mike huncapeller was to basically be
able to put all four reactions into a
single lane
run this on a gel and then look at the
bottom of the gel as the base
as the fluorescence came off and each
time you would see a color come off
you could say oh that was a color
indicative of an a and this is the
sequence of about 300 base pairs of a
fragment
now this still had to be further
improved to be efficient enough for
whole genome sequencing
so the revolutions were that the first
generations of this were still done on
gels
but once they switched to capillaries
reusable capillaries
you could put many samples through the
same capillary on successive runs
and the while the first generation had a
single capillary
then they realized that you could do
multiple capillaries for example a six
capillary sequencing device all the way
up to a 96 capillary device
when this became possible we had the
development of a machine around 1995
that was known as the abi 3700
this was a 96 capillary sequencing
machine which is shown on the slide
basically you have 96 simultaneous
reactions which you can put on
on a plate those those reactions will
then run through these 96 capillaries
they will run and then a ccd camera at
the end
can determine the sequence with this
automated sequencing machine
it had the capability of generating 75
000 base pairs of sequence
each time the machine ran and the
machine would run in three hours
with this type of thing and this is the
vision of craig ventner
here is a picture from solera genomics
in gaithersburg maryland
of the room that contains 330 of these
sequencing machines
this is the sequencing factory that thus
has the capabilities
of tackling something as complex as
craig venter's genome and his genome is
the first
named genome that was sequenced so with
96 capillary sequencing and a three-hour
run time
they were able to generate 31 million
base pairs of sequence a day
and thus in three to four months could
generate the complete genome sequence of
craig ventner
and when they put it all together they
didn't just use the sequencer
and sequencing by didioxy sequencing
they also use the efforts of physical
and genetic mapping
to help to string this all together they
also did not map the entire genome they
only mapped about 85 percent of the
genome because regions that were highly
repetitive it was very difficult to
determine when you sequence them exactly
where they came from
now once this was done the greatest
impact
was that it provided information on
genome organization which accelerated
all biological research
these are high throughput methodologies
rapidly developing
but the actual cost the sequence costs
for doing this on these abi 3700 is
about 200 million dollars
so what we need is dramatic improvements
in this
thousand million fold improvements in
sequence output
at decreased costs and this led to the
development of what are now called next
generation sequencers the cost again
they say it's about three billion
dollars that's to buy the machines and
get everything set up
well the reason that it was so expensive
as i mentioned before is
every single piece had to be
individually cloned into e coli
and each individual reaction was 10
microliters but you had to do
millions of these tiny fragments for an
entire genome the two together make it
so expensive
so to bring genome sequencing to the
masses you have to figure out to
dramatically decrease the cost of genome
sequencing
it raises the question how much would a
genome have to cost before it becomes a
routine part of standard clinical
practice
but first you have to solve the two main
problems the cloning problem
and the cost for the reagents well all
of these are called
massively parallel sequencing as i said
before this is mps and they're all
mps technologies so first thing you
needed to do
is to find a way to amplify individual
molecules separate from each other
unfortunately because of this it limits
the fragment sizes that you can do to
about two hundred to a thousand base
pairs in size
well to figure a way to amplify them the
first thing is to replace cloning
and there were two different pcr
strategies one is called emulsion pcr
the second is called bridge
amplification that were used to amplify
fragments
but those two are both dependent on pcr
amplification
the third is a pcr-free strategy to
analyfy
and that's called dna nanoballs now
caudal amplification is shown here in a
motion pcr
basically you make a water and oil
emotion
which puts tiny little water droplets
that only hold about 50 picoliters
in an oil emotion and what you do is you
have tiny little beads
the beads have nucleotides on them
oligonucleotides that are attached to
them
the dna fragments that you are trying to
sequence or the entire genome is
fragmented into pieces
the pieces have oligonucleotides
attached to the ends of them
which are exactly complementary to the
nucleotides that oligonucleotides that
are on the bead
so if you have a tiny little water
fragment and a tiny little bead with a
single piece of dna
that can be a pcr generator that can
amplify
that individual fragment a separate
droplet that's away from this one
will have another piece of dna and it
will amplify that piece of dna and the
separate droplets enable you
to amplify individual fragments of dna
to very large numbers
the second strategy which is not
dependent on these oil emulsions
is bridge amplification here the
oligonucleotides which on the previous
one were on the surface of a bead
are now on the surface of a flow cell
the dna that you want to sequence is
broken into pieces
oligonucleotides which are complementary
to the oligonucleotides of the flow cell
are put on the ends
and you have a dna the fragments are
flowed across the slide surface
and then one end will have an
oligonucleotide complementary to many of
the
oligos on the thing if that attaches the
other end can bend over
and find its complement and now you have
a bridge
and the bridge can then enable you to
start with a single fragment
to make two copies of the fragment and
when those are denatured you can repeat
this process
and what you end up with is clusters
that are amplified
sequence of the individual fragment and
on the surface of the flow cell
you can have lots of individual clusters
without the need for the messy oil
emulsions
however the first two techniques are
still pcr dependent
now the third technique is to use dna
nanopoles this was something that was
developed by roddy dramanczyk and
coworkers at complete genomics
what this does is you clone the
individual pieces of dna into a little
adenoviral vector
and then you use a phi polymerase which
basically runs and into rolling circles
to copy the dna without the pcr
amplification this is a linear
amplification
each individual molecule is copied to at
least 300 copies
those tiny little piece of linear dna
folds up into something
that's called a dna nanoball and those
nanoballs can then be deposited
into a pattern flow cell which is shown
on the right of that slide
so you now have the three different
techniques for amplifying dna
the second thing is how to reduce the
reaction volume again the 10 microliter
reactions have used a considerable
amount of reagents
so there's two different techniques that
we use to decrease the reaction volume
the first strategy was to put clusters
on a slide surface
the second was to have small beads on a
slight surface or in with wells
so the clusters on a slide surface are
done basically with
the bridge amplification the small beads
on a slide surface or within wells
are what is done basically with emulsion
pcr
i didn't describe it here the third
strategy of course is the dna nanoballs
which can then be deposited into the
little wells
all of this then is what leads to
massively parallel sequencing you're
using technologies analogous to
massively parallel computing
where in computing you just have
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
chips
each doing a small bit of the
computation well in massively parallel
sequencing
each individual sequence is a small bit
of sequence
but if you do this on hundreds of
thousands or millions you're doing a
large amount of sequence
the very first sequencing machine to
develop used pico
tighter plates pico tighter plates were
made by basically using fiber optic
cables
which have a hundred one and a half
million fibers in them
you slice the cables like a salami coat
the bottom of the plate with plastic
and you have these tiny little plates
that contain one and a half million
wells
and the very first commercially
available massively power sequence
was from a company called 454 and it was
called the gs20 for the genome sequencer
20 because it could do
20 megabases of sequencing remember that
the abi 3700
did 75 kilobases of sequence per run
so this is a dramatic improvement the
process overview is to first
amplify the individual molecules in
emulsion pcr
so you like it the the primers to the
dna you
amplify them on the beads you purify the
beads that have amplified dna
and then you put the beads with
amplified dna into the picotiter plate
that plate with the necessary reagents
for
base incorporation can be placed into a
machine and then you can flow
first the base a and to see if any of
them have incorporated an
a the two enzymes that are also present
there
are the enzymes for pyrosequencing they
convert a base incorporation to a flash
of light
so you have a camera at the top that
watches when you've incorporated and you
float a
through it to see if any of the wells
have incorporated an a
then you follow the second bit g c and g
to c and you can repeat this process as
a result of this and you can see this on
the right
you can actually determine the sequence
of that individual bead but remember
this is a picotiter plate
with 1.5 million wells so there are at
least
500 to 600 000 wells that have an
amplified bead on it
and that's how many sequences you're
determining simultaneously
now the strengths were that the reads
were long they'd started about
200 bases but very soon they got to 400
bases
then they made some improvements to make
it even longer but the weakness was that
it was a motion pcr which is a
cumbersome
technique the second one is that
actually the bases that are being
incorporated are unblocked
so you have a long string of a's or t's
or c's that is known as a homopolymer
all of those bases will be incorporated
and it's very difficult to discern the
difference between 10 and 11
19 and 20. the second weakness was that
even though there were
dramatic improvements on this machine
this improved from being able to do 20
megabases of sequencing per run
to 500 megabases but there was no room
for further improvements
in this now as this evolved and this is
shown here
they started as a gs20 a 20 megabase
sequencer
but very soon by increasing weed lens
they got this to be a hundred gigabyte
sequencer
then when i say current generation this
was the final generation of that machine
they coated the plates with titanium the
machine we called became the gs
flex titanium which could generate 500
megabases of sequence
and utilizing this machine the second
main person whose genome was sequenced
was jim watson
and this was done on these genome
sequencers at a cost of a million
dollars so this is at least a 200 fold
improvement
but again can we bring genome sequencing
to be even less than that because at a
million dollars this is still
way too expensive for for this to be
done
except for perhaps the richest people on
the planet
well the second sequencing machine that
became developed
was called the illuma genome analyzer
was actually developed by a company
called celexa
but illumina purchased alexa for 600
million dollars to get access to the
technology
the aluminum machine uses bridge
amplification
as i showed you before on the left is
actually the
individual flow cell that is present in
the little machine there's actually
eight lanes in it
so you have the capability of putting
different samples in each lane
this is then placed into the machine and
the illumina
had a number of key advantages over the
454 machine the first one was that
all four bases because they were put
with different fluorescent colors
can actually be put in together you
didn't have to do them sequentially
the second thing that was a really
important advantage is the fluorescent
groups that were added to each of these
nucleotides was placed in a position
to inhibit more than a single base being
added
so in one fell swoop they made this much
more efficient
they also made it so that you could only
add one base at a time so they solved
the homopolymer problem
what's shown on the right is the very
first basis that incorporated
after that base is incorporating you've
taken a picture of it you can add
chemicals to remove the fluorescent
group once you've done that
the base is actually ready to accept the
second base
and that base can be added again a
fluorescent group is put on a blocker so
it's a base at a time
and on the right you show the sequence
of the first round the second round the
third round the fourth round
and for example you take the little dot
on the left the first base incorporates
a g the second is a c then a t then a g
then an a that is the sequence c t or g
c t g a of that one position
the advances on this machine because the
very first machine
was capable of improvement over the 454
machine it could generate a gigabase of
sequence
which was 48 million clusters on the
eight lane flow cell
but the read length was very short it
was only 31 base pairs but over the next
three years
they increased the number of clusters
and relent to over 100 base pairs
which increased the number of gigabase
sequence at higher accuracy
a few years later a high seek 2000 was
the second generation aluminum machine
this had a number of dramatic
improvements including running two
slides
had a much greater sequence output and
as a result
even though the very first machine was
only capable of the gigabases sequence
when the high c2000 started it was
capable to do 200 gigabases of sequence
however once they started improving what
eventually you reach the point this is
shown on the bottom right
the number of clusters was so great that
it was very difficult to discern one
cluster from another
illumina took an idea that roddy
germanic first developed
for complete genomics which is instead
of having just random clusters on a
slide
to actually amplify in basically a
pattern flow cell that has tiny little
dimples what you do instead is you
amplify the dna in the dimples
and when you get the sequence when you
get the signal coming out of that and
this is shown in the middle
you can see a much more defined feature
with ordered spacing
which made it easier to discern one from
another and get a much higher
number of simultaneous sequences that
could be generated
the current generation of the illumina
platform is the novaseq platform and
this is
one of the machines shown here actually
there were two
novaseq machines the 5000 and the 6000
the 6000 is the highest throughput
machine and one of the nice features of
this
is both of them have the capability of
running different size
flow cells depending on how much
sequence you want to generate but with
the highest
output flow cell which is shown on the
top right it was capable of
three terabases of sequencing and since
the machine ran
two of these that means the machine can
generate six terabases of sequence
output per run
this is a 6 000 fold improvement
over the original sequencing machine
from illumina what is shown here is the
output that was generated first on the
genome
analyzer which started at a gigabase in
about 2007
by the time the machine retired it
increased its output to about
60 to 80 gigabases the high c2000
started at 200 but with improvements was
able to break the terror-based barrier
to generate more than a terabase of
sequence
now with the novaseq machine this can is
capable of generating even six times
more than that
six terabases of sequence output
another platform that was developed was
also developed by jonathan rothberg
so it used many of the same capabilities
of the sequencing that was done on the
454 machine with some improvements
one of the first was the sequencing is
actually done on
chips tiny little chips that look very
much like computer chips
they look like them because they're
actually made the same way
what you have is a wafer which instead
of being used to make
computer chips is being used to make
these tiny little chips
that have basically a bunch of little
dimples in them
each dimple is the equivalent of a ph
meter
the reason for the name ion torrent is
that when a nucleotide is incorporated
into a growing chain a hydrogen ion is
released
if you have a tiny little beat smaller
than the beads on the 454
that has a base incorporated all of the
amplified molecules on that bead will
release hydrogen ions
and as the ion torrent which changes the
ph in the well
so you put that all together you
basically are incorporating a nucleotide
releasing a hydrogen ion
and that is detected as a change in the
ph in that well
you then use the same methodology that
454
utilizes you flow an a t a g and a c
which of those bases gives you a change
in ph
the problems was the output on this
machine is still a fraction of what a
lumen is capable of
they use the same nucleotides that are
used in the 454 machine which are
unblocked
which means that if you have a long
stretch a homopolymer all will be
incorporated
and thus it's difficult to determine the
precise sequence of long homopolymers
in addition it's still cumbersome as
compared to alumina because she's still
doing
the emulsion pcr and as a result of this
alumina
continues to totally dominate the
massively parallel sequencing space
there are less expensive first
generation sequencing platforms because
most of the machines i've been
describing before
are high output machines that are
relatively expensive
a company genexis is developing a
low-cost machine but has a low output
and that raises the question how does it
stack up against aluminum or ion torrent
into space
alumina has an electronic sequencer that
is called the
ic 100 which is capable of 1.2 gigabases
it does two times 150 base pairs of
sequence at the end of every fragment in
19 hours iron torrent now has a genexis
system this is an integrated
lower cost system which can supposedly
get
specimen for a clinical specimen to
report in a single day
it's an automated workflow at a lower
cost
so what to sequence you now have
machines that are capable of generating
up to six terabases of sequence output
you also have some of these lower output
machines
if you don't need to sequence that much
well because you have these machines
you can now tackle a variety of things
everything from a whole genome
and when i'm talking about genomes it
could be the genome of a human
it could be a genome of an animal or it
could be a very small genome like a
microbial genome the only difference is
the size of the genomes differ
perhaps whole genomes is too much
information and you don't need it
well there are capabilities of the
sequence to find portions of the genome
and by defined portions that could be a
few genes all the way up to
the exome which is every single axon
there's 200 000 in the human genome
you may instead of being interested in
the dna be interested in the rna what is
actively being transcribed
that is the transcriptome now as i
mentioned earlier
there's more than four bases there's
also that fifth base 5-methylcytosine
which is a basically the epigenetic
modification
that is known as the methyl and with
sequencing depending on what you want to
do
you can choose these different things
but what are you trying to determine
do you need the sequence of the entire
genome to answer your question
is the structure of that genome
important because short read sequences
are very good with sequence accuracy
but since the short read sequences are
not very good for characterizing
our genomes or any complex genome that
are highly
filled with repetitive sequences
well let's talk about wgs whole genome
sequencing
to do this even though the genome is six
gigabases in size the three gigabase
from your mom and the three gigabytes
from your father
um you need to sequence more than that
because these are random fragments
so we think of about a hundred gigabytes
of sequence
which is a 30x whole genome sequencing
is
enough to generate the sequence of the
genome however if the genome you're
characterizing has heterogeneity and
this is certainly seen in many cancers
where you get a group of cells but
they're not all the same you will have
to sequence
more but when you've generated all that
sequence
how does one assemble that sequence
together how do you analyze the
assembled genome and again
raises the question what are you looking
for
well there are problems with whole
genome sequencing with the pattern flow
cells
on the novaseq 6000 machine the actual
sequencing cost has dropped
from hundreds of million dollars to only
475 dollars however
that is just the sequencing cost how
much to assemble the genome and
interpret it
what happens if you're looking for
alterations outside the coding sequence
what is their clinical significance only
about one to one and a half percent of
the genome
actually codes for protein so the
majority of genome
98 99 is outside of that coding portion
so what does it even mean and the
analysis of that is not trivial
there's also storage of all the data so
as a result of all these things
most of this means that whole genome
sequencing except for specific instances
is not yet ready for prime time clinical
practice where is it being used
well the clinical use that one of the
most exciting areas
is from the very pioneering work of
stephen kingsmore and his colleagues
where they have been using this in the
neonatal intensive care units
children are born that are failing to
thrive and science people want to know
right away what's wrong parents are
hysterical
and they also want to know and in this
instance
stephen kingsmore has developed
technologies where he combines the
aluminum machine in a fast run mode
to generate sequence data to interpret
that data
and have it all done in if this is an
older slide 26 hours it is now in less
than 24 hours
as a result of this this work became a
part and
went into the guinness borough the book
of world records however
when you do this type of sequencing in
the nicu unit you traditionally will do
the sequence of both parents
and of the child the total cost of that
today is about fifteen thousand dollars
as a result of that work we're starting
to realize that this
might be the model where neonatal
intensive care units
start to look at their children who have
problems they're also exploring whole
genome sequencing
in the context of rare diseases to find
out what is wrong right now
one of the largest uses of whole genome
sequencing are in population-based
studies for example genomics england in
collaboration with the national health
service
is planning in the next year and two to
do 500
000 genomes to sequence them they've
actually completed the sequence of a
hundred thousand
individuals from the united kingdom but
they have a collection of five million
people from the uk
and plans to actually sequence all of
them and the idea will be
to see if whole genome sequencing can
transform
clinical practice and helped transform
the national health service
the united states has a project which is
known as all of us
and this is the united states collection
of a million people from the
u.s linked to genomic information and
across the world there are about 50
different projects
and it is estimated by several people
that within the next five years
this type of work will lead to the
sequence of at least 50 million genomes
this is the largest use of whole genome
sequencing that is occurring today
as i mentioned earlier alumina actually
has a monopoly on massively parallel
sequencing
they themselves estimate that they have
about 90 of the sequence market
i believe it's probably even greater 95
and while there are currently first
generation mps alternatives
um illumina is controlling the sequence
space
and up to now was the only viable
platform for whole genome sequencing the
ion torrent system
perhaps the genopsa system are much more
lower throughput machines they could be
used for clinical sequencing of smaller
things
like small gene panels but certainly for
whole genome sequencing
there is only alumina and in spite of
the fact that the other machines could
be used for smaller projects alumina
still has a monopoly
this does not serve the scientific or
clinical community because something as
important as sequencing
which could become an integral part of
health care and well-being
should not be controlled by a single
company well is there an
alternative and the answer is yes that
answer
is the bgi or the beijing genome
institute
they have a variety of million genome
initiatives
from looking at a million newborns to
look at millions of plant and animal
genomes
as well as the many millions of
microorganisms well
the bgi is actually centered at a place
that is that has the china
national gene bank and this is a huge
storage facility
that has 20 million samples stored for
sequencing they have large numbers of
sequencing machines
and they have the capability to generate
a large amount of data
what bgi did was they purchased the
company complete genomics that was
developed by roddy dramancic and
co-workers
and they then started to utilize the the
complete genomic sequencing platform
this that platform is critically
dependent on the use of dna nanoballs
and again as i mentioned it's a novel
method to amplify fragments
using a five polymerase to linear
amplify templates to 300 copies
the amplified dnase folds into nanoballs
hence the name
it became dnb sequencing which can then
be deposited on pattern flow cells
the original bgi machines bgi again
purchase complete genomics
utilize a chemistry that was very
similar was a sequencing by synthesis
that will certainly have patent problems
against aluminum
however very recently roddy dramancek
and co-workers
have developed an alternative method for
doing sequencing
to try to get around those patent issues
and what they do this is called
cool ngs cool ngs because the actual
nucleotide incorporation that occurs
doesn't occur with a nucleotide that has
any
fluorescent on it any radioactivity they
simply use
nucleotides that have a blocking group
on them it's a reversible
blocking group and those bases are first
incorporated
after a base has incorporated a growing
chain because it's a blocking group it
can only add a single nucleotide
what happens after that is they
basically use
antibodies which are base specific
antibodies
that can then bind to that block base
each
antibody itself actually is shown here
has multiple fluorescent groups on it so
you get signal amplification
so you basically use the cold
incorporation first
you then follow with the antibodies with
the different fluorescent groups on them
you get a fluorescent group attached you
take a photograph of that
and when you're finished you chemically
remove both the antibody
and the blocking group that's the
blocking group on the cold base
and now you're ready for the next base
incorporation
and this is how the bgi sequencing
platform is currently working
they also develop a machine they have
various machines with different outputs
but their highest throughput machine
is a machine called the t7 the t7 is
called a t7 because it's capable of
generating
seven terabases of dna sequence output
per run
so it's quite comparable to the nova seq
6000
now what's very exciting about this is
that with bgi sequencing
most of which is done in house by bgi
but
on machines similar or just slightly
smaller than
the t7 they are capable of doing whole
genome sequence for a total cost of six
hundred dollars
this is significantly less than what it
would cost on the illumina platform
which includes everything
library prep sequencing alignment and
limited interpretation
recently bgi on the t7 machine
is decreasing that cost to just 400
this generates what what is known as 30x
whole genome sequencing approximately
100 gigabases of sequence output
well they're setting up plans to make
this more high throughput
to enable the various million genome
projects with the goal of generating
whole genome sequencing at the cost of
just 100
to do that they recently announced that
the advances in genome biology and
technology
meeting roddy germanic gave a
presentation about the platform that is
shown here
this is the platform that basically
modularizes
the dnb base sequencing the dna nanoball
sequencing there's a robotic arm in the
middle
this the slides there are multiple
slides that can be run
and this thing has tremendous output
this has
output that is on the order of 50 to 60
terabases of sequence output
and with this type of machine they will
be able to
generate genomes for a cost of just 100
the advantage of the sequencing platform
is there's no pcr in the amplification
process
as a result there are less pcr-induced
errors
when you amplify your individual
fragments as a result of this with no
pcr inducers there are less problems
when you put barcodes on different
sequences from different individuals and
put them all together
you have less barcode misassignment
cool ngs also uses multiple fluorescent
groups on each base
specific antibody as a result of this
they get signal amplification
which gives them the capability for
further improvements
the dnb ctx the tx for high throughput
can do 30x whole genome sequencing for
just a hundred dollars
while the current generation the dna
nanoballs is 200 nanometers in size
and that gets a sufficient signal but
because the antibodies have multiple
floors
on it it should be possible and rodney
dramanchik was talking about this
to make even smaller nanoballs that are
just a hundred nanometers in size
when they're that size you'll get an
even greater sequence output
so there's the capability of getting
genomes for significantly less than even
one hundred dollars competition is good
as bgi rams towards providing a genome
for a hundred dollars all
in illumina is going to have no choice
but to try to compete
or to try to inhibit vgi from selling
machines due to potential patent issues
which
are questionable we have seen a
reduction in whole genome sequencing
from 3 billion dollars
to 600 or less in just 19 years with the
capability
of the hundred dollar genome being very
close well once we have the hundred
dollar genome how long until it's even
improved further we've gone
from million-fold improvement in
sequence output
from just 20 years ago and we're almost
at the dawn of the hundred dollar genome
and with some of the
advances that roddy draunchick is
talking about we could see a sub hundred
dollar genome
why is the hundred dollar genome the
turning point more than anything else
for many years the target seemed to be
the thousand dollar genome
well the first reason that it's a true
turning point is when genomes just cost
a hundred dollars it really facilitates
population based genome sequencing
studies much more rapidly
the plans to sequence 5 million
individuals
in the genome england project will
cost considerable amount of money when
it costs 1 000 to 200 000
per individual but if it costs just a
hundred dollars
the possibility is that it's going to be
easier to do
less expensive and many other countries
will do similar efforts
and studies like the one from genomics
england and the national health service
will reveal the value of whole genome
information to direct health care
and at 100 or less whole genome
sequencing could become a routine part
of our medical record
and this will really get us much more
towards a fully envisioned personalized
medicine
more importantly we can start to
transform the paradigm of health care of
one where people are treated when they
have disease
instead to having a better understanding
of who might develop disease
based on genome sequence and we may also
have the capability of
basically having healthier populations
based upon
information from genome sequence and
possibly other information like what
would be ideal diets
would be ideal exercise regimens which
might be very much dependent on the
genome that you've actually inherited
well what aren't we seeing with all of
these first generation massively
parallel sequencing technologies
the two major competitors in this area
really are alumina and bgi
they only sequence fragments that are
relatively short and
taking these short fragments and looking
at genomes that is 45
repetitive is very very difficult all
the first generation mps certainly
aluminum bgi are very good for base
calling accuracy
but they're very poor for characterizing
large structural alterations
which are an important part of cancer
and many other disease states
there's other problems with the first
generation mps platforms
all are short we technology so again
it's difficult to generate the complete
genome sequence of a complex genome or
of a highly rearranged cancer genome
in addition you cannot when you use this
for rna sequencing
and looking at transcripts transcripts
many of them are considerably larger
than the sequence list
of the first generation technologies so
when you sequence
if you get a tiny little piece you don't
know which transcript isoform it came
from
so if you could sequence longer pieces
you could determine exactly which
isoform you're looking at
the other thing is that it's not
possible to directly use first
generation technologies to look at
genome-wide methylation with these
technologies
you have to take the genome sequence it
take that genome
bisulfite modify it to change all the
five methyl cytosines to uracil
and resequence it again so you actually
have to sequence the genome twice well
this leads rise to second generation mps
technologies
whereas all first generation
technologies which are highly dependent
on amplifying dna molecules
second generation technologies are
single molecule sequencing technologies
because you're doing single molecules
you don't have to amplify them
which means that you can look at much
larger pieces and because you're not
sequencing a copies of copies you can
actually sequence
much greater lengths and actually both
of the technology
that i'm not going to describe but i'm
just going to talk about briefly
can now sequence fragments that are
sometimes in excess of a million base
pairs in length
the two main platforms in the second
generation mps technologies
are pacific biosciences and we're very
pleased that dr jones carlos my friend
who's the chief scientific officer of
pac bio
is going to have a talk in in this
webinar where he's going to be talking
about some of the exciting things that
pat baier was doing in this sequencing
space
the second sequencing company is oxford
nanopore
and my colleague dr mark edward who's at
the mayo clinic
has been using oxford nanopore
sequencing to reveal portions of the
genome that are completely hidden
to short read technologies the last two
parts of the webinar that are part of
what i'm discussing are the clinical
uses of massively parallel sequencing
and my colleague dr matt ferber who's at
the mayo clinic
will talk about his work to develop
analytical and visual tools for
interpreting massively parallel sequence
data
my other colleague kevin holling also at
the mayo clinic
will talk about his work because he's
developed rna-seq rna sequencing
as a clinical assay to detect
translocations in cancer
i thank you for your time and your
attention
thank you dr smith for that outstanding
presentation
for additional informative presentations
view our agenda on our events page
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email
thank you again for your participation